So let's look a
little more closely
at aperture settings,
which in fact is
a discussion on, really,
what we call depth of field.
Depth of field is
about what is in focus
and what is not in
focus in your picture.
Your aperture
setting on your lens
sets the size of your aperture.
Or maybe it's easier to
think of it as a hole.
The size of that hole determines
how much of your image
is in focus.
When you set your lens
to the largest aperture
that your lens offers, we say
that your lens is wide open.
And in that wide
open setting is what
you see in your view finder.
If you want to see what is in
focus through your viewfinder,
that is, if you set your
aperture, let's say, at F/32,
you'll have to press
the 'Preview' button
to see what will be in focus.
By pressing the 'Preview',
the aperture will close down
to your chosen F-Stop, and
you'll see a darkened image
in your viewfinder.
It's another reason
why I use the software.
Remember, in the
software's Live View,
we see the image with the chosen
aperture on the screen much
easier than seeing
a darkened image
and trying to figure
out what's in focus.
There's no need to
press a 'Preview'
button when you use software.
So in our situation, two
eight is the largest aperture
in this particular 105 lens.
We call it F-stop
2.8 , or F / 2.8 .
Notice that the number is
actually written as F over 2.8
.
When we set the diaphragm
to those numbers written
on the lens, the numbers
in fact represent fractions
and for that reason
F over two eight
is larger in terms of size of
the aperture than, let's say,
F over 4.
And F4 is larger than
five six, and so on.
This can be a little
confusing, but if you
think in terms of fractions,
it will make more sense.
So these are the settings
we'll look at in this exercise.
You'll see more potential
settings on your lens.
But for our purposes
here, these should
be enough to make the
point about focus changes.
We'll stay with these five.
Okay now here is the image I
made of our music box at F/4.
Take a hard look at what is
in focus and what is not.
Not very much in the foreground
and background, and so we
say this image has a
narrow depth of field.
Not a whole lot is in focus.
Now at 5.6, here
is the image again.
Let's compare the two.
We're seeing very
slight changes in focus.
That's what we're looking for.
Take a hard look
what's in focus.
And now we'll go to F/8.
And comparing F/8 to five
six, little by little,
more of the image is
coming into focus.
You should stop the video and
give the two a careful look.
Notice the turning mechanism
a tad more in focus in F8
and a tad more as well in the
screws and everything else
in that object plane.
We'll go to the
next F-stop, F/11
and we'll compare to
the previous image, F/8.
And again, you should stop the
video to make the comparison.
And just to move
things along a bit,
we'll just go right to F/32.
Look at how small
the aperture is.
And look at how so
much more of the image
is in focus compared
to the previous.
Now to drive home the
point even further,
let's compare F/32 with F/4.
So you really see a
significant change.
That's what these
observations are about.
We're seeing how focus
or depth of field
changes more and more, get's
into focus, as we close down,
or stop down the aperture
to the smaller fraction
settings on your lens.
But remember, as we
close the aperture
to smaller settings
like F/32, we also
decrease the amount of light
we let into the camera.
We're not getting
the right exposure
until we compensate by
increasing the amount of time
the shutter is open.
For example, when I change from
one second [clicking sound]
to two seconds
[clicking sound], I'm
keeping the shutter open
twice as long, allowing
more light into the camera.
The longer the shutter
is open, the longer
we permit the light
to enter the camera
and to be read by the
sensor, compensating
for the small aperture setting.